hey it's a pleasure to meet you how's it
going nice to meet you
i'm good how are you i'm good how much
fun was it
to come into this show and get to
essentially like be the muscle
like going toe-to-toe with owen wilson
and bossing tom hiddleston around
it was really fun it was really fun
i am i i really loved going to work
every day i loved going to rehearsals
and the stunt training
and yeah it was great it was
it was fun it was you know and you know
owen and tom like to improvise too
so i got to really like and delve into
that side of
that side of me that i don't you know
could be a little you know
a little cheeky little little hot you
know salty
it comes across owen seems like such a
like a chill dude right like he's always
come across that's the way
his personality what's it like on set
does he
does he exude that energy does it make
it easier to do
work with him oh he's so
chill and so easy going and so
lovely and sweet and like
love stories and loves talking about
relationships and
you know like and and and hearing about
the things that make you tick like we
look
we talked about like what it was what we
were like as children and
our families and you know our hopes and
dreams our pets our everything we talked
about everything
and he's very very
you know he's exactly who you want him
to be that's like
bonding that's proper bonding oh yeah
you got our bond today but you've got to
you've got to trust each other and
and and rely on each other you know yeah
so you know in this show we talk about
um the nexus points
right where timelines diverge for you
what was the nexus point for you where
you got to actually go on this career
path you're on now and can you imagine
yourself in the other timeline
that's a big question uh can i imagine
myself on the other timeline
i trust that wherever i was gonna
wherever i end up i was gonna be okay
and
i do have that faith in in
in i have that faith that will be okay
and it's you know life is what you make
it and
and you know i mean i say that like that
sounds
kind of arrogant but it's it's not
exactly what i mean but it's
like you it's it's your
outlook right a lot of the time and you
know your lessons
it's how it's not how many times you
fall but how many times you get up and
all that stuff
so i do believe that the versions of
women on the timeline
i you know i mean i guess i don't know
i don't know i don't know um but i would
say
my nexus event was going to drama school
it was going to
it was choosing to be an actor and um
funnily enough i was in drama school
with tom tom was my third year and i was
first year
yeah so i watched him you know in my
first year in all of his shows and
really looked up to him and um
yes i would say that was a nexus event
because i was you know
i'm here now and if i didn't get into
drama school
i was going to go do maths and economics
at
university and i think i would have
still enjoyed
that i may not have um i
mean we we wouldn't be here talking
right now but
yeah i think i would you know my life
would have been different but i think
it would have you know i thought
but so cool that you know that you and
tom got to get back together on this
that's fantastic yeah
i'm loving the show so far i can't wait
for more um it's been a pleasure
chatting with you thank you so much
thank you have a good one
you